I mean it's really kind of a no-brainer
you can't complain if you don't
contribute so use your voice use your
right and votes that was taraji P Henson
talking to et live on the Ralph breaks
the internet red carpet just last night
taking some time to urge people to get
out there and vote on Election Day
so taraji is one of many celebrities
encouraging people to rock the vote this
year to talk through Election Day I am
joined now by my former colleague zach
toombs of Newsies that covers politics
global issues and does documentary work
and lives and works out of none other
than Washington DC Zach thank you for
being with us thank you
so is that I want to talk to you because
this is what you do this is an area that
we as ET and as people in entertainment
news get into only at certain and very
important times of the year people are
saying that yes celebrities have been
involved in politics but this election
feels different do you get the sense
from people in DC and the actual
politicians running our country that
they feel celebrities are more involved
in these midterms than they've been in
elections past definitely I mean this is
probably the biggest day in American
politics in two years since the election
in 2016 there's a sense among Democrats
that you can't sit on the sidelines for
this one so we've seen celebrity
endorsements of candidates who've seen
Oprah going out on the campaign trail in
Georgia for the governor's race there
for the Democratic candidate we've also
seen a lot of celebrities just saying go
out and vote not even specifically
supporting one candidate or another but
just saying hey exercise your right and
of course today is election day but
people could have been voting in recent
days are what numbers are we seeing so
far there's Taylor Swift she just posted
today that she went out and voted
celebrities both encouraging people to
register and now saying get out there
and vote what numbers are we seeing so
far in terms of how these midterms are
looking turnout wise yeah I mean
basically a lot more people are expected
to vote and already have voted in these
midterms than done past midterms usually
it's the presidential contest three four
years
all the attention and the midterms are a
little sleepier this time
36 million people had voted early as of
yesterday last year or rather in 2014
the last midterms that number was 27
million so several million more in three
states including in Texas or they got a
hot Senate race going on right now
more people have voted early this year
than voted overall in 2014's midterms
and like you said a hot race there any
other of the races that you just want to
highlight that are going to be the ones
to watch today right in Texas you've got
better or ork and Ted Cruz going through
the US Senate seat there in Florida
there's a race with Andrew Gilliam as
the as the Democratic candidate for
governor and and then in Georgia the
race that Oprah has has waited in to
Stacey Abrams running for governor
versus Brian Kemp obviously a very
conservative state so if Democrats can
flip that that governors see that would
be a major one all right Zach Toombs
thank you so much of course everybody
get out and vote today is the day and we
will see whether all of the celebrity
push has made a difference thank you
thanks
[Music]